good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
imagine your photographer living near
the southern shore of lake vättern in
Sweden on your commute to work each day
you pass a tree in a lakeshore park that
looks kind of like a huge stalk of
broccoli and the broccoli tree always
makes you smile there's just something
about a single tree in an otherwise
empty landscape something that makes
farmers harvest around them and you to
put them on album covers and then one
day in the spring of 2013 you take a
picture of the broccoli tree on your
iPhone camera and post it to Instagram
there's a bit of dirt on your lens it's
certainly not the fanciest picture
you've ever taken but people like it 43
people in fact over the next few months
you upload a few more photographs of the
broccoli tree the pictures aren't only
about the tree but also about the life
happening around it a bird in the sky a
jogger a happy couple in November you
post a picture of the tree with a
caption saying that you're reminded of
an old quote you don't take a picture
you make a picture that one gets 107
likes by April of 2014 11 months into
the project you're posting a few
pictures of the broccoli tree every week
and you decide to give it its own
Instagram the tree becomes a focus of
your creative life you photograph it
through the seasons in rain and snow and
sunshine capturing the people who line
the beach for the brief and glorious
Swedish summer luxuriating in the
broccoli trees shade your audience grows
into the thousands in the summer of 2015
you have an exhibition of your broccoli
tree photographs at the broccoli tree
and your pictures keep getting better as
the project becomes more popular the
broccoli tree calendar is a success and
people all over the world buy broccoli
tree prints for their homes by 2016 the
broccoli tree project is so successful
that the broccoli tree is becoming like
famous people visit it as a tourist
destination and you find yourself in the
surreal position of photographing the
broccoli tree while people are
photographing themselves with the
broccoli tree type the broccoli tree
into Google Maps and you're taken there
immediately
you can even street view it sure by
sharing the broccoli tree so widely it
has come to belong less to you and your
close friends but it's amazing that so
many people are seeing your photographs
and that what started as you looking at
a tree on your commute has become this
huge deal the broccoli tree now has over
27 thousand followers on Instagram which
means that you are the photographic
force behind the social Internet's
single most famous tree and then
on September 27th 2017 you go to
photograph the tree in the morning but
something is different upon close
examination it becomes obvious in a
furious and heartbroken Instagram post
you right you absolutely cannot unsought
REE and indeed the damage proves
irreversible a few days later it's gone
the broccoli tree once your broccoli
tree is no more you loved something you
shared it many people loved it too and
then one or a few people decided to cut
it down given enough time such people
will always cut down such trees the
Joshua Tree from that u2 album cover
gone the sacred golden spruce tree in
British Columbia gone the location of
the oldest tree in the world of 5,000
year old Bristlecone pine somewhere in
California is kept secret because
otherwise we all know what would happen
to share something is to risk losing it
especially in a world where sharing
occurs at tremendous scale and where
everyone seems to want to be noticed
even if only for cutting down a beloved
tree if you'd never photographed the
broccoli tree it might still be there
for you to see on your commute every day
it might still provide shade to the real
people who live with you on the southern
bank of that lake but then again the
faraway people who loved your pictures
of the broccoli tree were real too they
took shelter under its canopy as well
even if only virtually and the truth is
if we hoard and hide what we love we can
still lose it only then we're alone in
the loss you can ton saw a tree but you
can't unsee one either the broccoli tree
is gone but its beauty survives Hank
I'll see you on Friday